the end of the world as we know we are
back to everybody I'm Tim let's Adam I'm
hanging out that's Tim we're hanging out
there's a ton of news yes there is it's
it's starting it crazy because I guess
people are freaking out but I have this
really funny article that I wanted to
lead with Yahoo actually published this
guy hell is coming here is the
mathematical proof but this is truly a
glorious be Idol statue for the future
that late-stage capitalism yeah I think
I ends the first like the hope this
story is hilarious it's basically like
we what not hilarious no it is there I
mean it's not a coin of humor in there
right basically this guy wrote an
article where he's like hundreds of
thousands will die
so we're bullish on hospital stocks make
sure you invest it gonna be a great
return after everyone dies mm-hmm yeah I
love it there's a bunch of other stuff
too so we've got you know illinois' now
on lockdown we got the big three that's
Chicago New York Los Angeles all closed
makes its spreading that the lock downs
are coming and we have a media that is
begging for a national lockdown begging
for it so there's been a bunch of
articles saying like it's gonna happen
it's coming it's happening mm-hmm now
we've got we have one from the hill
literally saying shut us down please mr.
president
bring on the martial law and send out
the army and all it you know stuff
they're doing that in Italy and so I
decided you know take a look at these
people that are clamoring for a national
lockdown as we're looking at a country
actually doing it so first of all China
did it yeah yeah they're you know
insane locking people in their homes and
stuff like that and then we have Italy
that is now bringing out the army to
enforce the lockdown like people in
Britain and in Spain are getting
arrested for breaking quarantine there's
some reports that tapping in Israel -
and friends - right or no I don't know I
I read probably don't be surprised and
so now we have people in our own country
saying that we need the military to come
out there been a bunch of viral videos
of like Humvees and and military
vehicles on trains being like shipped
through Chicago and stuff like that
people are freaking out tagging me in
though but I think it's gonna happen you
know why we've got data showing that and
and and we were pointing out before the
show the data might be unfair right but
it shows that the u.s. is
tracking faster than Italy and according
to one bit of data the u.s. is is seeing
more cases of coronavirus it's growing
faster percentage-wise than any other
country right so our curve of growth
infection rates is steeper than all the
other countries now that's percentage
based so the thing about the Italy stuff
is that get a much bigger population so
if we see more cases well that's just
because we have way more people yeah but
the percentage percentage is where we
get shots get freaky so we just had I
think like six hundred and seventy five
deaths in one day in Italy that's a lot
and you want to know why that brought in
the military just to move the bodies
right to move the bodies yeah that's
crazy man
people don't people people under under
estimating this and it's not some videos
they're doing at night so doesn't freak
people out really yeah the end is nigh
so last night somebody finished the show
I made sure to run into the middle of
the street in front of my house and
started just doing the Joker dance yeah
yeah I just had to do it I took one foot
on and I was like this is too much but
it was a matter of principle yeah I will
not be contained and then I was like
okay I'm done I'll go back inside I'm
tired yeah came back in like I got
nowhere to go
that was fun yeah let's just go back
inside so uh let's uh let's just jump
into it let's just do it but before we
do if you guys want to hop into super
chat we'll read your comments as most of
you know once we start getting inundated
with too many super chats we have to
sort of speed things up and we've been
getting really slammed but I appreciate
all the support for sure so we will do
our best to rate as many as we can in
between the segments so we got it oh no
the stories celebrities are going insane
yeah we just yeah yes it's not really
surprising though cuz most celebrities
are insane yeah they're like aren't they
egotistical narcissistic and so they're
they react weird when they have no
attention well and I mean we were
talking about youtubers would get
depressed when they their views are down
imagine like a list celebrities that are
used to just like paparazzi yeah what
are you doing what are you now locked in
their bathroom now they're in their
house dude with absolutely nothing sorry
I said wait a minute
I said dude that floor bo sam smith was
apparently crying oh yeah breaking down
having a mental breakdown I don't even
know
that is it's the pits the floor bows the
floor bow who got I can't do it it's
this guy he's a guy I'm sorry he's a
dude this is the dude that got sued by
Tom Petty for he did it you know that
song it's like I won't back down oh yeah
oh I won't back down I remember this
whole thing and then his song was like a
slower version that was only similar in
that one part yeah and he got sued I
thought it was kind of dumb because and
Tom Petty won right yeah yes I think
it's stupid because Sam Smith's like a
he's you know he's like 20 did he even
know who Tom Petty was that's what he
says I don't even this guy is I've never
heard this song before you know is the
craziest thing then we find out that his
mom played it like wow she was in his
womb or in yeah well this happened the
headphones over you know no it's not
that it happens a lot that people will
hear a song right on the radio and they
won't know they'll start humming it yeah
I have them to me right me the other day
what was that song oh that was a Billy
yeah Billy a song do you say Billy I
lied you know it's really crazy though
remember that song what's it what's it
called you know the one where like the
three dudes are like dancing and then
blurred lines like the naked women are
dancing and stuff they got sued and lost
really because the beat sounded too much
like I think I can Marvin Gaye song beat
really that's insane to me it's like
wait time I was like a drum rhythm and
you got they got sued over it I all I
know is the Weird Al song were bored
crime word crimes came out and that was
amazing that's a good song is so good
everyone needs to go check that song out
of the music video the music yeah and
the music video is awesome too
alright let's let's read this story hell
is coming here is the mathematical proof
drama and then from there we'll take a
look at the reality mm-hmm so here's
this guy says and I'm not gonna read too
much of the X we're going to go through
his math but he says right now two
million Americans are infected with a
corona virus the total u.s. death toll
by April 15th will be more than 20,000
we estimate that 80,000 of the 2 million
infected Americans will be hospitalized
over the next two weeks that's why we
are short term bullish on hospital
stocks there's here as your financial
advice trying to like throw some humor
in there or no this is this is a legit
financial advisory newsletter
yeah so first of all I don't know where
he's getting that number two million
Americans are infected
I think he's extrapolating so he goes
through the math he basically makes an
estimation based off of so when you look
at the Japanese diamond princess okay he
looked at the amount of people on the
ship the amount that were tested the
amount that were positive and the amount
that were died and then from there blows
up his estimation to American
proportions and comes to the conclusion
there are you know two million people
are infected I think it's all silly but
sure whatever but what's really funny
about the story is that it's it's
basically this long explanation of how
you know Trump is shifting the blame to
China and we're gonna have all these
people you know dying in the average
recession the sp500 NX declines by 32%
do you think this is going to be an
average recession so here's what he says
hospital stocks will financially benefit
from near 100% utilization rates because
usually their utilization rates hover
around fifty percent so is it's it's
basically this is where we are today so
so it's great for anyone who has stocks
in hospitals yes and and he's advising
you to short term do it there was
another there was another bit of
financial advice I was reading where
they basically said this is gonna come
in waves
everyone's predicting there'll be
another wave in November and that we at
we might actually go into two months of
lockdown one month of like open activity
two months of lockdown one month open
until everyone gets it and then they're
immune to it yeah and that'll go on for
nearly two years so a vaccine exercise
November December 2021 that's that's
that was MIT reviewer that story and
because of that people are saying like
these financial advisors are saying
don't get back in the market period and
they were like put options like bet the
stocks will fail yeah that's where we're
at
that's what I'm thinking like I have
zero interest I was like when it first
started happening and it was still like
is it a scare is this is this real and
there was like a that the first day
there was like that massive drop and I
was like oh maybe I should buy some
stocks and I didn't yeah I was like it
was at 25 and I I'm glad I didn't and
now I'm like I I don't want anything to
do with this as we lost now it's it now
it's it
dipped briefly below like 1900 it's
crazy man I mean I'm dead what say it's
gonna keep dropping don't you think I
mean oh yeah totally
well check this out boom Ovid nineteen
cumulative cases US vs. Italy 11 day lag
so apparently what they're trying to do
with these graphs and we've seen graphs
like this before is to sync up first
reported cases from like you know the
USA or something so the dates don't
really make a whole lot of sense right
but you can see that the growth so I'm
perhaps is a different chart maybe
they're graphing by the amount of people
infected period but what we end up
seeing is that by March 20th relative to
where Italy was when they saw their
first infected we're almost double yeah
and the thing that's the really
important factor here is that the US is
above a 33 percent daily increase and
there's I believe there's the only other
country that's closest Spain and Spain
is actually just below that so the UK is
just below it to I think the US might be
the only country now that's well above a
33 percent daily increase that means
every two days were more than or you
know we're adding well that there's you
go 33 percent daily increase
we're also according to that first
article doubling our deaths every three
days Wow and we're doubling the total
infections every two or three days good
yeah welcome to the lockdown man it's
coming yeah what's a women plan feels
like we need it and like everyone I mean
we see this and we see what's happening
it's like who's gonna be upset about it
who's gonna want to go outside I don't
want to go to the store I know I mean
you don't want to go anywhere I want to
stay in this house and stay away from
people but you know what gets me like
it's kind of crazy that you always hear
these dystopian stories about how the
government's gonna come down and demand
you know you learn lock you in your home
you like be able to speak or say things
mm-hmm no everyone's begging for it
right now they're saying please please
remember in 1984 we never thought it
would be voluntary that they'd be
watching us with cameras either and yet
here we are we want to be in front of
you exactly you know it was somebody
read 1984 and they were like you know
what it's not an instruction menu
that mean we're there like 1984 wasn't
supposed to be an instruction manual and
held up signs saying it no it wasn't it
was like tips and tricks you know so
basically the authoritarians looked and
they're like oh that's why these things
don't work we need to make them want to
do that
yes that's a demócrata democracy dies
with thunderous applause yeah the line
from Star Wars a year from now we find
out coronavirus was not as bad as that
we you know we don't get is it's gonna
be low I know but then you know they
they put it in these laws like in a very
fine print the very bottom that if this
is just the way it is now no dude we
just can't go out we're not gonna find
out it's good it's it's gonna be you
know 20 years and then there's gonna be
some dude who like finds an old file and
like blows it off and he like he opens
it up and then it's like the conspiracy
and he's gonna go my god and then
there's gonna be someone you could leave
well enough alone could you prepare and
injection inject some yeah sure oh no
virus yeah the governor of Illinois
Pritzker oh is that no oh really I was
just trying to come up with a random
name for like the journalist it's
actually cuz I'm looking at it right now
that's probably what it was I'd even
realize I'm looking at the yeah or it
could be that Governor Pritzker uncovers
the the Colonel virus conspiracy in 20
years he's an old man he's like our
current believe it it was a trick like
you couldn't leave well enough alone
could you Prince Barin
Pritzker yeah I must have I was reading
it and I just like picked up the name
but uh well let's do this first so
Illinois's under lockdown obviously I
mean New York is in a shelter-in-place
it's funny because I was talking to a
friend up in New York and they were like
I'm gonna leave I don't want to be stuck
in the city and I was like leave now we
go leave now and he's like yeah I mean
what's the worst gonna happen I'm like
they're gonna make you stay in your
house and you they won't build to
enforce it I'm like dude watch yeah and
watch well there you go buddy there you
go buddy enjoy being in New York till
Sunday right right he needs to leave now
or tomorrow you know what not touch
anyone
right yes stable all right no your he
was over here like a couple weeks ago so
pumpin feet with us yeah he was like
you can touch my elbow well new New York
is the epicenter now word yeah right
what a ttle what yeah yeah yeah now is
Seattle that's crazy not something or
New York which that's what I said it I
knew it was gonna happen soon as it hit
New York it was gonna be like boom and
sure enough New York so dense yeah it's
crazy there's so many people there and
have you gone to they're like like fish
markets no I never like when you go to
Chinatown
Neverland this shows never big it's just
like open trays of fish over ice it's
like oh yeah
yeah dude no the skate past it's um you
know Manhattan has a certain aroma that
I would say is akin to sour milk it
depends on the season actually yes yes
yes this midsummer it is sour melt ripe
the city smells so bad really dude but
if you're skating fast enough yeah skate
past the smells you know it's really
crazy to me is that I went to I've been
to a bunch of hermit countries mm-hmm
one of the one of the craziest things
I've ever experienced was I was in
Morocco
okay and I was transferring I landed in
Casablanca and I was transferring now
then to Marrakesh and so I'm in the
Casablanca Airport and I'm following the
signs to find my connecting flight when
all of a sudden the lights as I'm
walking down the hall
slowly stopped working flickering and
then off and there's a sign pointing and
I turn and it's just dark like no lights
at all and there's like holes in the
wall and I'm like clearly I must have
taken a wrong turn yeah and I am no
longer in the functioning part of the
airport when I'll send a guy in a suit
like normal looking like American kind
of guy yeah he just like walks past me
wheeling his suitcase and I'm like I'll
follow this guy yeah and then as we made
our way through it really did look like
I was in an abandoned building hmm and
then eventually we made it to an open
area where the lights started turning
back on and there were some shops and
this was like normal looking and clean
and I was like dad was crazy all right
so anyway I bring that up cuz is a funny
story but I've been to a bunch of these
countries and I always kind of look
around at the ground and stuff okay and
I find it interesting like in Egypt
driving along the highway you can see a
bunch of buildings that are falling
apart or like never finished being built
and I was like wow and then I came back
to the US and I was like I'm glad you're
back in America where everything's like
you know built
together and then I was in I was in
Brooklyn and I was like no well then
wait a minute like seriously there are
parts of Brooklyn I know that are busy
areas we're all rows of buildings that
are just boarded up and empty and I'm
like you know I have to wonder is this a
simulation and are those the ones they
never bothered to design the inside of
that's we can't go in them well there's
been an uptake of like rent control
being running out you know people no
longer can afford the landlords suddenly
go from you know getting 500 bucks a
month to demanding three grand a five
grand a month well
CBGB's was like 1,200 bucks yeah a month
for a while and then the landlord was
like all right ten grand now yeah and
CBGB's was like okay we're closed right
somebody else sorry yeah but basically
you know Manhattan what's happening all
over the place yeah but like even in
Manhattan take a look at the ground man
you know as trash everywhere it's trash
it's cracked it's brittle a broken the
buildings look awful it's one of the
biggest things I couldn't stand about
New York I actually watched my neighbor
walk out to her car and open the door
and clean her car out by just throwing a
trash on the ground there just like not
a little bit of trash all of the trash
it's oh dude I I didn't know what to do
I have seen people driving in Manhattan
open their doors and just kick out trash
yeah but like all over the street that
place and it and that's why it's like I
kid you not skating in Manhattan gives
you a certain perspective yeah most we
don't realize because you have to dodge
the sour milk and yo gods a lot you got
people tourists cars cabs that's that's
Chicago that's all a yeah I knew you're
now it's LA is not like New York Ohio
isn't either
well downtown Chicago now if Chicago's
bright hours
Chicago's like a pushed out sprayer
Chicago I'm scared I've skated around
down but Manhattan is like New York's
New York City is like five down on
Chicago's all jammed into one yeah
pushed together yeah but yeah but you
know I frequently dodge those be like
there's like the water has like a hint
of milk in it in New York everywhere all
the time and you can smell it and
Chicago dies the the water green and it
just stays green remember when
Matthews fan they don't even need to dye
it anymore that bits it's already green
we're good remember when Dave Matthews
Band bus drove over the bridge and the
guy pulled the sewage line and dumped it
all over the people in that boat no no
this this happened I'm pretty sure Rose
I'm pretty sure was Dave Matthews Band I
don't get really like well it's Dave
Matthews poop so no then the band is no
of the band but so there was a riverboat
with like people having like a wedding
or something you know like fancy suits
and likes him in their wine and they
went under the bridge right as the bus
went over it and the bus driver was like
I don't want to deal with going to the
RV camp to drain the toilet so we just
pulled it and it sprayed everything dude
people don't understand oh I laugh but
that it's so gross I feel so bad for
those people I don't know if you've ever
actually dealt with draining an RV I
have you all for a while the black water
travel around Europe it's black slime
yeah it smell right everything up yep
into us actually it'sit's not that bad
actually when you have a good like
there's these the canister things that
you go outside and you pull yeah I'm not
talking about draining it I'm talking
about what it is and spraying all over a
bunch of people who run out yes I know
what it is and that's why I feel really
bad for I wouldn't jump I jump in the
river I'd be like just jump over or like
everything else be damned yeah how else
can you get rid of it like get it off
you quick I'm really appreciating how we
totally deviated off of like the world
it was a great story deep doubt but I
can't believe you missed that one that
was no no I been out I've been I left
Chicago when I was 19 so I was like I
don't know 16 years ago or something Wow
17 years ago yeah yeah but it was still
big news yeah but really pay attention
too much outside of my world you know
well anyway man I'll tell you waiting
you know I think where we can tie this
all in is I I've spent all of my life in
big cities except I'd like the brief
stint wait a year in Miami we were in
the we are in the like the Redlands
boonies maybe the boonies man yeah but
relative to like some rural areas I've
spent time in not so much like yes not
big city we are 40 miles outside of
Miami but
still like relatively I wouldn't call it
a suburb I mean yes technically it is it
was it's crazy I didn't think of it as a
suburb now you know that what was that
that city that was just was a hometown
or something home something Redlands
no no just south of us I mean right I
know I don't I don't remember the name
of it but that's where one of the
detention facilities was were like kids
and cages were so really held like
literally like a few miles away from
where my oh right there yup
what was that place called I don't know
I'm sure I'm sure people know but here's
the thing man i I've I've actually now
gone to much many more rural places it's
like when I was driving I drove all the
way in the country several times and I
decided on one of my trips to actually
just get off the interstate and take
like us roads and like common roads very
different it's so different you know it
didn't smell like sour milk you know
it's surprising when you get out there
and and the cities in this country are
filthy yes they are
yeah man and the people that live there
are filthy they are they're very filthy
but in their entitled pretty much
America though I mean I've I've well I
can't say for the rest of the world but
I traveled around Europe a lot and when
I was living in the RV and people throw
away their trash there's no trash on the
grounds I mean I saw it it was there but
not very very often I mean I looked for
it I started was like man there's really
nothing and then I started looking for
it and I'd be like wow there's a piece
of trip oh no that's not trash over here
funny anything else but when hear a
funny Chicago story of course I was
downtown and they had this big bin
there's like a rectangular shaped
garbage thing okay and on one side it
said I was like recycling and the other
side was garbage and then I looked in
and guess what it was what it was a
shoot going into one guy there you go
just there's like no matter what you put
in it was like into the trash but make
you feel better right sure so yeah
Illinois is being locked down now I I
don't know what's what they spiked to
happen but check this out let me let me
let's let's jump back into it could
trump declare national coronavirus
shutdown momentum is rising and might I
add it's also I mean yeah momentum is
rising you're the ones who published
this shut us down already mr. president
this is
scary article dude yeah the dude
basically says bringing them bringing
the martial law here it is look at I'm
talking martial law do it you said
you're now a wartime president so act
like one
jeez all businesses should be closed
except the essential ones and that list
should be carefully constructed no
travel no planes no cars no movement we
stay in our homes and leave only to get
food go to the doctor or walk our dogs
or well guard dogs
I love the dog walking like the world is
ending bring on martial law but we have
to walk our dogs
let us talk he clearly has a dog he
clearly has a dog well I mean dude going
back to the cities any non-essential
businesses should be closed down do you
hear about Game Stop is plaint claiming
their their essential dude then even
sell games anymore like they do while
they're trying to become a knick-knack
store I know they're yeah they're the
blockbuster of gaming's I tweeted this
last night it's like yeah they're I
don't go buy games anywhere download my
games we go to the malls playing jaws
downloaded doom mmm we go discs we go to
the mall we walk in a game stop look at
the games that are listed and go oh I'm
gonna go download that when I get home
yeah no I don't do that but that's what
well they're trying to do now is they're
trying to sell knickknacks yeah like if
you want to get your little Link and
Zelda dolls mm-hmm Game Stop yes so
they're they're Blockbuster meets Hot
Topic they're trying so they bought it
I'm I think no one buys that stuff who
buys those pop things anyway they were
doing really bad for a while you know
why they still I mean you know think
geek like didn't isn't there it sounds
familiar it's like a geek shop on the
internet door oh that's a didn't it
yeah isn't there isn't there a game stop
think geek store in Manhattan it's like
on Sixth Avenue I don't know yeah never
be honest so that's what they were
trying to do they were trying to be a
place where you can go for your silly
nerd stuff like your t-shirt that says
like you know it's got the green
mushroom from Mario on it or something
every single console that has come out
you'd app you can download they have a
the store you can get any game right I
don't understand why we still make these
plastic pieces or or the discs that will
just no no no no the PlayStation spits
it out all the time yeah well there was
actually a reason for that well
the destiny playstation that I had had a
malfunctioning button no my you're right
they all did that did that he had this
thing we're like there was pressure on
the bottom where the button was that
would force it open it happened at all
time
yeah playing like horizon zero dawn I
actually so it's been this guy opened
that PlayStation up and disabled that
the button yeah so you can't hit it but
it fix it I was just like up the helmet
for my own games so anyway the dude in
this article basically says science step
determined with confidence from the
hundreds of thousands of cases reported
so far the recommended period for
self-isolation should be 14 days and
then he says because we we are Americans
we do more make it 21 I kind of feel
like this guy's joking are you serious
like it's bad enough yeah you know right
exactly but I'll tell you what man
what if we're always one step behind
this thing and so instead of making it
better we actively are making it worse
while the virus still just smashes its
way through our society through our
country natural selection like people
have like the insensitive people are out
there calling it dude let it run its
course let it kill people let it bubble
bubble bonds like like these the I saw a
viral video of a bunch of like young
people on the beach yeah doing shots off
each other and stuff yeah
and I'm like well and that's and and
people are wondering why the American
numbers are spiking more than the Italy
numbers well do you know that the
Spanish flu predominantly hit young
people really young people but it could
be because they were in it was a lot of
young people in war know close quarters
but what I was reading from Stanford was
that there was a previous flu in the
late 1800s so the older crowd had
already some flu immunity the younger
kids didn't have it okay and so when the
new virus hit it was much much harder
and some older people that had partial
immunity based on like like strains so
young people got hit really hard but
here's a crazy thing the first wave in
the beginning of the year hit the
elderly and young people were mostly
okay the second wave in August hit the
young people and was devastating so
they're predicting multiple waves on
this one I'm willing to bet we're gonna
see a bunch of young people
in the hospital because these these kids
are as dumb as a box of rocks they have
they really are it's not it's not all
young people it's just the young people
that are dumb are going out and partying
we'll call them the skull crackers yeah
yeah yeah yeah the skull skull break
your jaw breakers there's a data data
released by basically every news outlet
and basically every you know
organization tracking this shows the the
largest bracket of hospitalizations is
22:54 now that's wide you know and it
could still be mostly 4254 mm-hmm but
they separated it that way and it's
basically 29 of all hospitalizations and
then 55 and above comes up to like a
smaller number maybe I'm getting wrong I
think it's 22 44 I'm probably the
numbers wrong I don't have the article
pulled up so sue me yeah but that's
there they broke it up into several
different brackets and I think I
mentioned it the other day what they're
saying is young people are actually
really likely to be hospitalized but
respond really well to ventilation okay
older people don't so it says what does
that mean yeah so the old people aren't
aren't going and I think you all getting
the respirators or whatever they do and
then ventolin so here's what I think
would make sense in that regard is
ventilation is gonna save your life if
you can't breathe young people have
strong bodies and so when their lungs
fill up with fluid
the ventilation works their bodies heal
and takes in the oxygen older people
struggle to heal of weaker immune
systems their lungs fill up with water
or fluid they can't breathe and the
ventilation doesn't do enough to
actually save them so you'll see more
apparent what they're saying more young
people in the hospital but they respond
really really well to to the treatments
all the people die thanks for checking
out this segment from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show every Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. sometimes an
hour or two and we do have a full live
recorded version of the show that
includes a lot of comments and smaller
segments you probably don't see if you
want to check that out you can watch
live at 8 p.m. Monday through Friday or
become a member of this channel and for
five bucks a month you get full access
to all of the recorded podcasts every
day after the show we make them
available in the community section of
this YouTube channel so don't forget to
subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the
next show
you